The podcast 20,000 Hurtz is a show about the world's most interesting and recognizable sounds. I think of it as almost a sibling of 99% invisible, lovingly produced and reported deep dives into everyday things that make you see the world differently, or in the case of 20,000 Hurtz, make you hear the world differently. We've collaborated a number of times over the years, but we're featuring them today because our sibling podcast produced an episode with my actual sibling, Lee Mars, co-author of the book, Golden, the Power of Silence, in a world of noise. Lee showed up on a mini-story episode of 99PI a few months back, talking about the ever-increasing
播客《20,000 Hertz》是一档关于世界上最有趣、最易辨识的声音的节目。我认为它几乎是《99% Invisible》的姊妹篇，通过精心制作和报道，深入挖掘日常生活中的事物，让你以不同的方式看待世界，或者就《20,000 Hertz》而言，让你以不同的方式聆听世界。多年来我们合作过多次，但今天我们要特别介绍他们，因为我们的姊妹播客制作了一期节目，嘉宾是我真正的兄弟李·马尔斯（Lee Mars），他是《金色的沉默：喧嚣世界中的静谧力量》（Golden, the Power of Silence in a World of Noise）一书的合著者。几个月前，李曾在《99PI》的一个短篇故事集里露面，谈论警笛声越来越大，以此作为衡量我们世界变得有多吵闹的一种方式。但《20,000 Hertz》制作的这期故事更直接地探讨了《金色的沉默》的核心论点。我非常喜欢这期节目，喜欢它的呈现方式，并为所有参与者感到自豪，所以我只想把它作为一期特别节目分享给你们。享受吧。
loudness of sirens as a way of measuring how loud our world has become. But the story 20,000 hurts produced tackles the main thesis of Golden More Head On. And I love this episode, I love how it turned out and I'm so proud of everyone involved that I just wanted to share it with you as a bonus episode. Enjoy. It's an honor to be here with you all. That's Cyrus Habib. First, I want to just briefly tell you kind of what my job is, what my role is. It's fall 2019, and Cyrus is giving a speech to a large crowd in a busy convention center. He's wearing a black suit and dark sunglasses.
很荣幸能与大家在一起。那是赛勒斯·哈比卜（Cyrus Habib）。首先，我想简要告诉大家我的工作是什么，我的角色是什么。那是2019年秋天，赛勒斯正在一个繁忙的会议中心向一大群人发表演讲。他穿着黑色西装，戴着深色墨镜。
Most people year in Washington say to polite to ask the question, what do you actually do? For the last two years, Cyrus has been the lieutenant governor of Washington State. That means he's the second in command of the state's political system. As he talks, he grips a microphone in one hand and gestures to the crowd with the other. He looks confident, like the successful politician that he is. If things worked out for you this year, if your business did well, your family is doing well, I'll take the credit for that. People are predicting big things for his career.
华盛顿的大多数人太礼貌了，不好意思问这个问题：你到底是做什么的？在过去的两年里，赛勒斯一直担任华盛顿州的副州长。这意味着他是该州政治体系中的二号人物。他一边说话，一只手紧握麦克风，另一只手向人群挥舞。他看起来很自信，就像他所展现的那位成功的政治家一样。如果今年你们一切顺利，如果你们的生意做得好，你们的家庭生活美满，我会把功劳归于自己。人们对他的职业生涯寄予厚望。
They're already talking about him as a possible candidate for the next governor, even though he's still in his thirties. I'm for making sure that we give everyone the best opportunity, not any opportunity, but the best opportunity, not any opportunity, but the best opportunity. But Cyrus won't become governor. Because not long after this speech, he announces that he's giving up politics entirely, that he's becoming a Jesuit novice and taking a temporary vow of silence
尽管他才三十多岁，但人们已经在谈论他可能是下一任州长的候选人。我致力于确保我们给每个人最好的机会，不是随便什么机会，而是最好的机会，不是随便什么机会，而是最好的机会。但赛勒斯不会成为州长。因为在这次演讲后不久，他宣布完全放弃政治，他将成为一名耶稣会见习修士，并暂时发下沉默誓言。
and that he will now pursue a life of poverty, chastity, and obedience. In my office in a few different ways, first of all, no more speeches, in a program which is the first of its kind. No more applause. Cheers.
他现在将追求一种贫穷、贞洁和服从的生活。在我的办公室里，以几种不同的方式，首先，不再有演讲，在一个首创的计划中。不再有掌声。欢呼。
Cheers. Cheers. Cheers. Just golden silence. You're listening to 20,000 Hertz. Cheers. Cheers. to 20,000 Hertz. As I think back on my life, I was obsessed with the voice of the future, calling back to me, telling me you got to do this, you got to do this so that you can get to this other
欢呼。欢呼。欢呼。只有金色的沉默。你正在收听《20,000 Hertz》。欢呼。欢呼。收听《20,000 Hertz》。当我回首往事时，我曾痴迷于未来的声音，它在呼唤我，告诉我你必须做这个，你必须做那个，这样你才能到达另一个
place. Cyrus's parents immigrated to the US from Iran, and growing up, he was always determined to succeed. Perhaps this has to do with losing my eyesight to cancer as a child becoming blind, and forming a kind of compulsive need to be seen as successful. That urge to succeed continued into his political career. First, he served in the State House of Representatives, and then the State Senate. It was exhilarating for me to be around a lot of people. It was exhilarating for me to speak to huge audiences. It was exhilarating for me when we would have lobby days at the legislature
地方。赛勒斯的父母从伊朗移民到美国，在成长过程中，他总是决心要成功。也许这与我童年时因癌症失明，并形成了一种渴望被视为成功的强迫性需求有关。那种成功的冲动一直持续到他的政治生涯。起初，他在州众议院任职，后来进入州参议院。能和很多人在一起让我感到振奋。能向庞大的观众发表演讲让我感到振奋。当我们在立法机关举行游说日时，我感到非常振奋。
and you'd have thousands of people coming by. Cyrus's political future looked really bright. I was achieving more and more success. I had collected all kinds of accolades and achievements. But despite all of these achievements, he never felt satisfied. As those things were happening, I felt a greater and greater sense of emptiness.
会有成千上万的人过来。赛勒斯的政治前途看起来非常光明。我取得了越来越多的成功。我收集了各种各样的荣誉和成就。但尽管取得了所有这些成就，他从未感到满足。随着这些事情的发生，我感到一种越来越强烈的空虚感。
Each time I would obtain one, the desire would come even more quickly for the next thing. Worst of all, the voices in his head just wouldn't let him be. Voices of the past, you know, people suggesting that there's things I can't do because I'm blind, and I need to prove them wrong. Maybe voices from the future saying, you're gonna love it when you reach this next stage. Maybe voices of others in the present saying, SIRES, you really ought to think about doing this. SIRES, you're what our country needs. These are the kinds of voices, some fictional, some real,
每当我获得一样东西，对下一件事的渴望就会来得更快。最糟糕的是，他脑子里的声音让他不得安宁。过去的声音，你知道，人们暗示因为我失明所以有些事我做不到，我需要证明他们错了。也许是来自未来的声音说，当你达到下一个阶段时，你会喜欢的。也许是现在其他人的声音说，赛勒斯，你真的应该考虑做这个。赛勒斯，你是我们国家所需要的。这些声音，有些是虚构的，有些是真实的，
that had crowded out my own desires. Oh, my own desires, my own desires, actually had nothing to do with any of those things. To fix this, some people might try looking for a new job. Others might start exercising or spending more time with their family, but Cyrus had a different idea. I had read James Martin's book, The Jesuit Guide
挤占了我自己的欲望。哦，我自己的欲望，我自己的欲望，实际上与所有这些事情毫无关系。为了解决这个问题，有些人可能会尝试找一份新工作。另一些人可能会开始锻炼或花更多时间陪伴家人，但赛勒斯有一个不同的想法。我读过詹姆斯·马丁（James Martin）的书《耶稣会士指南》
to Almost Everything in which he talks about his life as a Jesuit, and so that had kind of planted a seed in me of interest in this life. What would it be like to live in a religious order? What would it be like to take v a religious order? What would it be like to take vows and to simplify my life drastically? What would it be like to live a life dedicated to serving others?
（The Jesuit Guide to Almost Everything），他在书中谈到了他作为耶稣会士的生活，这在我心中种下了一颗对这种生活的兴趣种子。在宗教团体中生活会是什么样子？发下誓言并极大地简化我的生活会是什么样子？过一种致力于服务他人的生活会是什么样子？
While he was still Lieutenant Governor, Cyrus decided to visit a Jesuit ministry. It's not a monastery. I mean, Jesuits are not monks, but still there is an order and a structure to the day. So you'll rise at 6.30 a.m. to 7.45 meditation prayer in chapel. 8 a.m. breakfast together. 8.30, a scullary, which is to say, you know, cleaning the pots and pans and the dishes and everything.
当他还是副州长时，赛勒斯决定参观一个耶稣会事工。那不是修道院。我的意思是，耶稣会士不是僧侣，但仍然有一套秩序和结构。所以你会在早上6:30起床，7:45在礼拜堂进行冥想祈祷。早上8点一起吃早餐。8:30，做杂务，也就是说，你知道，清洗锅碗瓢盆和盘子等等。
The whole day is planned out like this, right up until bedtime, the spiritual reading in the evenings, we are brought to vision in debit and the night prayer and chapel, and then whatever other prayer one does at the end of the night. Compare that to the life of a politician. Public life, you know, it is the life of the crowd.
整天都是这样安排的，一直到睡觉前，晚上的精神阅读，我们被带到……还有晚祷和礼拜堂的祈祷，以及晚上结束时做的任何其他祈祷。把这与政治家的生活相比。公共生活，你知道，那是人群的生活。
So it is quite noisy. Often there'd be multiple meetings going on in my office and I would be kind of shuttling back and forth from different groups because we had so many people booked. And it wasn't just his work life. Even in the car, I would turn on podcasts. But an old block calls for them to vote seven.
所以它非常吵闹。通常我的办公室里会有多场会议同时进行，我会因为预订的人太多而在不同的群体之间穿梭。而且不仅仅是他的工作生活。即使在车里，我也会打开播客。
And now I look back and I think I did try to squeeze every bit of input into my life, even in moments that could have been downtime all the way till I fell asleep. After a lot of thought, Cyrus made his decision. He finished his term in office, then sold his apartment. He gave up his possessions and left to begin his new life as a Jesuit. When people tell me, I'm so surprised, I'm so shocked, Cyrus, to hear that you left politics behind and you just career and everything to become a Jesuit and say, well, if you're surprised, how do you think I feel?
现在回想起来，我想我确实试图把每一丁点输入都挤进我的生活中，即使是在本可以是休息时间的时刻，一直到我睡着。经过深思熟虑，赛勒斯做出了决定。他完成了任期，然后卖掉了公寓。他放弃了财产，离开去开始他作为耶稣会士的新生活。当人们告诉我，赛勒斯，听到你抛弃政治，放弃职业生涯去成为一名耶稣会士，我感到非常惊讶，非常震惊，我说，好吧，如果你感到惊讶，那你觉得我感觉如何？
I mean, truly, I am still surprised. Cyrus made the most surprising career decision anyone could possibly imagine. That's policy advisor and political strategist Justin Zorn. He made an announcement that he was taking a vow of poverty, chastity, and obedience as a novice Jesuit priest. And in the New York Times, Frank Bruney described it as, politician takes a sledgehammer to own ego.
我的意思是，真的，我仍然感到惊讶。赛勒斯做出了任何人能想象到的最令人惊讶的职业决定。那是政策顾问和政治策略师贾斯汀·佐恩（Justin Zorn）。他宣布他将发下贫穷、贞洁和服从的誓言，成为一名耶稣会见习神父。在《纽约时报》上，弗兰克·布鲁尼（Frank Bruni）将其描述为：政治家挥舞大锤砸碎自己的自我。
Throughout his career, Justin's worked on all kinds of projects. Environmental justice, economic justice, climate, foreign policy, and I'm also a meditation teacher. I taught meditation on Capitol Hill. There were a few members of Congress who had a real just necessity to find a way to slow down, to tune into the breath, to tune into the workings of the mind and how to manage the neurosis and the intensity and the noise of life and politics. Like Cyrus, Justin finds that noise to be pretty exhausting.
在整个职业生涯中，贾斯汀参与了各种各样的项目。环境正义、经济正义、气候、外交政策，我也是一名冥想老师。我在国会山教过冥想。有几位国会议员确实有必要找到一种方法来放慢节奏，调整呼吸，调整思维的运作方式，以及如何管理生活和政治中的神经症、强度和噪音。像赛勒斯一样，贾斯汀发现那种噪音非常令人疲惫。
You know, cable news constantly running in the office. That's your choice. That's your choice. That's your choice. My choice. It's an on-stop parade of meetings and tours and phone calls and negotiations and fundraising sessions and emails and every requirement you can imagine at the auditory level of the noise
你知道，有线电视新闻在办公室里不停地播放。那是你的选择。那是你的选择。那是你的选择。我的选择。这是一场不停歇的会议、巡视、电话、谈判、筹款会议和电子邮件的游行，以及你在听觉层面和信息层面的噪音上能想象到的所有要求。
and also the informational level of the noise. Eventually, Justin decided to leave that noise behind. My wife and I left DC and we headed out to the mountains in the western US. And I was in the midst of a career transition. Around that time, he started collaborating with an author and leadership coach named Lee Mars. Lee was interested in many of the same ideas as Justin, and the two of them started working on a book.
最终，贾斯汀决定把那些噪音抛在脑后。我和妻子离开了华盛顿特区，前往美国西部山区。当时我正处于职业转型期。大约在那时，他开始与一位名叫李·马尔斯（Lee Mars）的作家兼领导力教练合作。李对许多与贾斯汀相同的想法很感兴趣，他们两人开始合作写一本书。
That book is called Golden, the power of silence in a world of noise. So we decided to just follow the cookie crumbs and start interviewing people, neuroscientists and poets and activists, and the question we came upon was, what's the deepest silence you've ever known? That question led Justin to Cyrus. This friend of mine had said, oh my god, you've got to meet this guy. You guys are just like, at the same intersection of politics and spiritual life. So I asked my friend to connect us, he did, and we had our first conversation by phone. The first thing Justin wanted to know was this,
那本书叫《金色的沉默：喧嚣世界中的静谧力量》。所以我们决定顺着线索，开始采访人们，神经科学家、诗人和活动家，我们遇到的问题是：你所知道的最深沉的沉默是什么？这个问题把贾斯汀引向了赛勒斯。我的这位朋友说，天哪，你一定要见见这个人。你们俩就像是在政治和精神生活的同一个交叉点上。所以我请我的朋友联系我们，他照做了，我们通过电话进行了第一次交谈。贾斯汀想知道的第一件事是：
what was it like going from a life that is defined by noise to one of silence and reflection? That was really hard. You're not on social media, you're not on the internet, you're not on the phone. of silence and reflection. I could be speaking to the media about some new idea or initiative, and what am I doing? I'm just scrubbing toilets again. These voices were telling Cyrus that he should go back to his old life, a life that was built around getting his ideas heard by as many people as possible. In a way, it's not surprising, because modern society
从一种被噪音定义的生活转变为一种沉默和反思的生活是什么感觉？那真的很难。你不在社交媒体上，你不在互联网上，你不在电话上。我本可以就某个新想法或倡议向媒体发表讲话，但我却在做什么？我只是在再次刷厕所。这些声音告诉赛勒斯，他应该回到他以前的生活，一种围绕着让尽可能多的人听到他的想法而建立的生活。在某种程度上，这并不奇怪，因为现代社会
is all about making noise and getting attention. If you look at the way our whole society is structured right now, even how we measure the economy, how we measure progress, our foremost measure of progress is also primed for the maximum production of mental stuff of sound and stimulus. But for Cyrus, the hardest part was still ahead, because as a Jesuit novice, he had to go through an entire month without speaking or being spoken to. He couldn't even write an email or send a text. The first few days were pretty hard, just because you're not used to silence. And, you know, after a couple days, you think, oh my God, it's been so long. And then you realize, oh my God, they're 28 more days of this.
一切都是为了制造噪音和吸引注意力。如果你看看我们整个社会目前的结构方式，甚至是我们衡量经济、衡量进步的方式，我们衡量进步的首要标准也是为了最大限度地产生精神上的东西、声音和刺激。但对赛勒斯来说，最困难的部分还在后面，因为作为一名耶稣会见习修士，他必须经历整整一个月不说话也不被别人说话。他甚至不能写电子邮件或发短信。前几天非常难，只是因为你不习惯沉默。而且，你知道，几天后，你会想，天哪，已经过去这么久了。然后你意识到，天哪，还有28天要过。
A vow of silence is supposed to help you discover spiritual truths. But when you experience something profound, it's natural to want to talk about it. Because I am an extrovert, it was hard for me to get over that instinct to orally verbalize things to other people. You know, I would experience something in prayer or I would think of something and I'd instantly wanna tell people about it. I'd wanna talk to my friends about it
沉默誓言旨在帮助你发现精神真理。但当你经历了一些深刻的事情时，想要谈论它是很自然的。因为我是一个外向的人，很难克服那种想要向别人口头表达事情的本能。你知道，我会在祈祷中经历一些事情，或者我会想到一些事情，我立刻就想告诉别人。我想和我的朋友谈谈，
or I'd wanna talk to my mom about it or someone I'm close with. So that was really hard. So I was really hard. Cyrus completed his 30 days of silence, and that experience taught him some valuable lessons. The first one was to focus on the moment. Mindfulness, which is a word that's used a lot, but which I really got to understand as a novice really came down to silencing those voices so that one can be attentive to the present, no matter what's happening. So that might mean being really attentive to the food I'm eating. It might be really attentive to the conversation I'm having or really
或者我想和我的妈妈或我亲近的人谈谈。所以那真的很难。赛勒斯完成了他的30天沉默，那次经历教会了他一些宝贵的经验。第一点是专注于当下。正念，这是一个被广泛使用的词，但我作为见习修士真正理解的是，它归根结底是让那些声音沉默，以便一个人能够关注当下，无论发生什么。所以这可能意味着非常专注于我正在吃的食物。这可能意味着非常专注于我正在进行的谈话，或者非常
attentive to the dishes I'm washing. You are encountering the divine. You are encountering beauty, truth, and goodness. In what you do, the key is, can you notice it? Do you notice it? The next step is discernment. Desirnment is about sifting through the noise of our world to find the signal amidst the static and the interference of our daily busy lives. And there's a lot of static out there. The professor at the University of Michigan estimated through years of research that the
专注于我正在洗的盘子。你正在遇见神圣。你正在遇见美、真理和善良。在你所做的事情中，关键是，你能注意到它吗？你注意到了吗？下一步是辨别。辨别力在于筛选我们世界的噪音，在日常忙碌生活的静电和干扰中找到信号。外面有很多静电。密歇根大学的一位教授通过多年的研究估计，
average person has to listen to something like 320 stated the union addresses worth of internal chatter in their head every single day. But with a little practice, you can turn down the chatter and focus on what you really care about, and that's when the real change can begin. Take for example someone who is in a relationship. Maybe two people have been dating for a year or so. And now, all of a sudden, they seem to be arguing all the time. That could mean any number of things. It could mean that there's an invitation there to change, to be kinder. It could mean there's an invitation to call the other person out and to advocate for oneself.
普通人每天在脑海中听到的内心喋喋不休相当于320次国情咨文演讲。但只要稍加练习，你就可以调低这些喋喋不休，专注于你真正关心的事情，那时真正的改变就开始了。以一个处于恋爱关系中的人为例。也许两个人已经约会了一年左右。现在，突然之间，他们似乎一直在争吵。这可能意味着很多事情。它可能意味着有一个改变的邀请，变得更友善。它可能意味着有一个邀请去指出对方的问题并为自己辩护。
It could mean there's an invitation to end the relationship. Who knows, right? Well, that's the question. We got to discern what's going on here and truly to believe that even in the most difficult circumstances, even in something like having cancer, even in something like becoming blind. There are myriad invitations to grow invitations to become more fully oneself, more fully human, but to find that still small voice, one has to go through a process of noticing and learning. Through this process, Cyrus managed to find his true inner voice. It was a voice that said, Deep down, I want to be nourished.
它可能意味着有一个结束这段关系的邀请。谁知道呢，对吧？嗯，这就是问题所在。我们必须辨别这里发生了什么，并真正相信，即使在最困难的情况下，即使在患癌症、失明这样的事情中。也有无数成长的邀请，成为更完整的自己、更完整的人的邀请，但要找到那个微小的静谧声音，一个人必须经历一个注意和学习的过程。通过这个过程，赛勒斯成功地找到了他真正的内心声音。那是一个声音，它说：在内心深处，我想要得到滋养。
Deep down, my heart desires a vocation, a life that is rewarding, that lets me be my loving self, that lets me grow in my loving, approach to the world and to others, a life of balance. So it's a turning inward to the self and it's also then a turning upward, a moving upward to the transcendent. [♪ Music playing in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background, in background quiet peaceful place, but how do you find that same piece in one of the noisiest most chaotic places on earth? You have a pre-paid call from...
在内心深处，我的心渴望一种使命，一种有意义的生活，一种让我能成为充满爱心的自己，让我能在对待世界和他人的方式上成长，一种平衡的生活。所以这是一种向内转向自我，然后也是一种向上转向，一种向超越者移动。在安静平和的地方，但你如何在地球上最嘈杂、最混乱的地方找到同样的平静？你有一个来自……的预付费电话。
Jarvis Masters and in Nadehant, the California State Prison San Quentin. My name is Jarvis Masters. I have been an inmate at San Corden Prison for almost 40 years. I hope you take time to live into my school. That's coming up after the break. Even in a quiet place, it can be really hard to find peace, because there's always the incessant chatter in our heads.
贾维斯·马斯特斯（Jarvis Masters），在加州圣昆廷州立监狱。我的名字是贾维斯·马斯特斯。我在圣昆廷监狱当了近40年的囚犯。我希望你花时间去体验我的学校。休息后回来。即使在一个安静的地方，也很难找到平静，因为我们脑子里总是有不断的喋喋不休。
But how much harder would it be if you were surrounded by non-stop noise? Finding silence in San Quentin Prison might seem impossible, but not for Jarvis is known as the Buddhist of Death Row. Jarvis first came to San Quentin in 1981 after pleading guilty to armed robbery. He was sentenced to 20 years with no possibility of parole. He remembers when he first arrived in his jail cell. Probably the first thing I was able to see was how low the ceiling was. I can put my arms to the side and touch both balls, you know. And I knew right then and there. I cannot see this every single day. So I was being buried alive.
但如果你被不间断的噪音包围，那会难多少倍？在圣昆廷监狱找到沉默似乎是不可能的，但对被称为“死囚牢房里的佛教徒”的贾维斯来说并非如此。贾维斯在1981年因武装抢劫认罪后首次来到圣昆廷。他被判处20年监禁，不得假释。他记得他刚到牢房时的情景。我能看到的第一件事可能就是天花板有多低。我可以把双臂伸向两侧，摸到两边的墙，你知道。我当时就知道。我不能每天都看到这个。所以我被活埋了。
His first years at San Quentin were pretty rough. I was stubborn, I was mad, I was angry, and all I was learning from San Quentin is what not to do. I never felt like I was being inspired to learn what to do. But slowly, his perspective began to change. I started reading these books about masculinity and what we do to imitate being what a man is supposed to be based on what we've been told. So I was reading a lot of these books and they were really good books for me to read because
他在圣昆廷的头几年非常艰难。我很固执，我很疯狂，我很愤怒，我从圣昆廷学到的只是什么不该做。我从来没有觉得我被激励去学习该做什么。但慢慢地，他的观点开始改变。我开始读那些关于男子气概的书，以及我们为了模仿别人告诉我们的男人应该是什么样子而做的事情。所以我读了很多这些书，它们对我来说是非常好的书，因为
they really started to tear away what I thought I should look like, sound like it'd be like. What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do?
它们真的开始撕掉我以为我应该看起来像、听起来像、表现得像的样子。最重要的事情是什么？
What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do?
最重要的事情是什么？
What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? What's the most important thing to do? case, but there are a lot of people who think Jarvis was wrongly convicted. His supporters include the Dalai Lama and Oprah Winfrey. Oprah even chose Jarvis' autobiography for her book club. Here she is explaining that decision on CBS Mornings. My intention is to let people know that there are a lot of people on death row and a lot of people in prison For whom there has been a miscarriage of justice and in this case
最重要的事情是什么？但有很多认为贾维斯被错误定罪的人。他的支持者包括达赖喇嘛和奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）。奥普拉甚至选择了贾维斯的自传作为她读书俱乐部的书目。她在《CBS早间新闻》上解释了这个决定。我的意图是让人们知道，死囚牢房里有很多人，监狱里也有很多人，他们遭受了司法不公，在这种情况下，
I believe there has been a miscarriage of justice Understandably Jarvis was devastated by the guilty verdict. He knew he might be sentenced to death But then he came across a book in the name of the book was Then he came across a book. The book was Life and Relationship to Death and I said they're in ready for almost a week while the jury's in deliberation. The book was written by a Tibetan monk and is based on a specific school of Buddhism called Vajrayana. It uses techniques like mantras and visualizations to help people become more self-aware and
我相信存在司法不公。可以理解，贾维斯对有罪判决感到崩溃。他知道他可能会被判处死刑。但后来他偶然发现了一本书，书名是……然后他偶然发现了一本书。这本书是《生命与死亡的关系》（Life and Relationship to Death），我在陪审团审议期间读了近一个星期。这本书是由一位西藏僧侣写的，基于一种特定的佛教流派，称为金刚乘。它使用咒语和可视化等技巧来帮助人们变得更加自我意识，并
accept their circumstances. You know, life and relationship to death was where I was and I just thought, hey, you know, let me try this." Soon after, Jarvis was sentenced to death. He spent the next 21 years in solitary confinement. During that time, he wrote to the author of Life in Relationship to Death, who came and visited him in prison. Then, Jarvis took what's called the Refuge Val, and committed himself to Vajrayana Buddhism.
接受他们的处境。你知道，生命与死亡的关系就是我所处的位置，我只是想，嘿，你知道，让我试试这个。不久之后，贾维斯被判处死刑。他在单独监禁中度过了接下来的21年。在那段时间里，他写信给《生命与死亡的关系》的作者，作者来到监狱探望了他。然后，贾维斯接受了所谓的“皈依誓言”，并致力于金刚乘佛教。
I became a student of that practice, and I thought that practice as I began to sit with it was a very clear honest way of opening me up to see where freedom really is. The first step was learning to be still, both physically and mentally. I had to learn how to sit down first before I learned how to meditate. I was a very angry person and I didn't particularly think sitting down was fulfilling for me at that time. So I just had to learn how to sit down with me, you know, and that took a while. There was a lot of times where I was bored with it, but I made a commitment for myself to just sit there.
我成为了那种修行的学生，当我开始坐下来修行时，我认为那是一种非常清晰、诚实的方式，让我敞开心扉，看到自由真正所在的地方。第一步是学习保持静止，无论是身体上还是精神上。我必须先学会如何坐下来，然后才学会如何冥想。我是一个非常愤怒的人，我不认为坐下来对我当时来说有什么成就感。所以我只是必须学会如何与自己坐在一起，你知道，这花了一段时间。有很多次我对它感到厌烦，但我对自己做出了承诺，只是坐在那里。
And being start opening up, gate start opening up, and that was a beautiful time for me, it really was. In 2007, Jarvis was finally allowed to leave solitary confinement. And that meant a lot more noise. But Jarvis kept using the techniques he had learned to find peace within that noise. Yeah, you're the noise, but I'm not listening. I can learn to give the noise just to, but not let it dictate what I want to do. I can walk around and feel very quiet within my own body, with my own way of thinking. And I guess that's been sort of like my meditation. It doesn't try to control what I do.
大门开始打开，那对我来说是一段美好的时光，真的。2007年，贾维斯终于被允许离开单独监禁。这意味着更多的噪音。但贾维斯继续使用他学到的技巧在噪音中寻找平静。是的，你是噪音，但我没在听。我可以学会给噪音让路，但不让它支配我想做的事情。我可以走来走去，在自己的身体里、用自己的思维方式感到非常安静。我想那就像是我的冥想。它不试图控制我做什么。
It tries to ease me through what I'm doing. It's a gift, it's a gift because it honors you in a way that allows you to receive a benefit of just pulling that silence, you know. It's a gift because no one knows what I hear but me. There's just a lot of noise to navigate on death row in San Quentin, and Jarvis is a master at it. That's author Lee Mars. Lee spent a lot of time interviewing Jarvis for the book Golden. Even when we're speaking with him on the phone, we can hear it in the background. There's just low fire radios and party beats going. And they're just men hollering at all times at day and night. And sometimes screaming in the night,
它试图让我轻松地完成我正在做的事情。这是一种天赋，这是一种天赋，因为它以一种让你能够获得仅仅通过那种沉默就能受益的方式来尊重你，你知道。这是一种天赋，因为除了我，没人知道我听到了什么。在圣昆廷的死囚牢房里有很多噪音需要应对，而贾维斯是这方面的大师。那是作家李·马尔斯。李花了很多时间采访贾维斯以完成《金色的沉默》一书。即使我们在电话里和他交谈，我们也能在背景中听到它。背景里总是有低保真的收音机和派对音乐。男人们日夜不停地大喊大叫。有时在夜里尖叫，
suffering, having nightmares. And this is all being reflected and bouncing off of concrete cement. It's a loud, loud environment. of concrete and cement. It's a loud, loud environment. And it's not just audible noise that prisoners have to live with. There's also informational noise.
受苦，做噩梦。所有这些都在混凝土和水泥上反射和反弹。这是一个非常吵闹的环境。而且囚犯们必须忍受的不仅仅是可听见的噪音。还有信息噪音。
All rise. Cases and appeals and documents, legal documents and the situation of their trials or retrials, and there's more information available than ever before for them to fixate on or perhaps to be a key to their someday release. And then internally, there's the reverberation of the state-synch-in-death and and trauma, regret and worry. Strangely, Jarvis finds it easier to find peace when the prison isn't totally silent. There's a certain amount of noise that is necessary for him to feel quiet in prison.
全体起立。案件、上诉和文件、法律文件以及他们的审判或重审情况，有比以往任何时候都多的信息供他们关注，或者可能是他们某天获释的关键。而在内部，有死囚牢房的共鸣，以及创伤、遗憾和担忧。奇怪的是，当监狱不完全安静时，贾维斯发现更容易找到平静。对他来说，在监狱里感到安静需要一定量的噪音。
If it gets too quiet there as you might imagine, it's not good. It might mean the guards are about to do a raid, you know, a search that something's brewing, some trouble is brewing. So he was describing it in this way that was really helping me understand. He's like, I like the noise because I like the silence right beside that noise. After 30 years of meditating, Jarvis has a lot of practice calming his mind, but even for him, it's not always easy. They can bother you in a way where you're overthinking things. You're trying to direct where everybody should be at.
如果那里太安静，正如你可能想象的那样，那不是好事。这可能意味着狱警要进行突击检查，你知道，搜查，意味着有什么麻烦正在酝酿。所以他以一种真正帮助我理解的方式描述了它。他说，我喜欢噪音，因为我喜欢噪音旁边的沉默。经过30年的冥想，贾维斯有很多练习来平静他的头脑，但即使对他来说，这也不总是容易的。他们会以一种让你过度思考的方式打扰你。你试图指挥每个人应该在哪里。
And that's a problem for me trying to push things to work the way it should work. I do start that way a lot of times, you know, frustrated. But rather than trying to fight that anger, he's learned to let it pass. I think for a lot of people, if accepting the fact that we might have to start our day off like that, if accepting the fact that hey, you don't blow him his face and you should have a problem with it because this is a full of meditation. Looking at this stuff and trying to figure out how to dissolve it into nothing, how does it move from what it is now into some kind of acceptance. Once Jarvis has found his inner silence, he can then start to listen to his internal voice.
这对我来说是个问题，试图推动事情按照它应该工作的方式工作。我很多时候确实是以那种方式开始的，你知道，感到沮丧。但与其试图对抗那种愤怒，他学会了让它过去。我想对很多人来说，如果接受我们可能不得不以那种方式开始一天的现实，如果接受嘿，你不要对他发火，你应该对此有问题，因为这充满了冥想。看着这些东西，试图弄清楚如何将它们溶解成虚无，它如何从现在的样子转变为某种接受。一旦贾维斯找到了内心的沉默，他就可以开始倾听他内心的声音。
But in his case, he's not listening for discernment. Instead, he's listening for compassion. What my whole trip is to find a gate that was just going to open me up to understanding how compassion works inside a prison system. I see guards spend a lot of pain and suffering, and I say, wow, this guard may be going home to his son. I would see violence, and I say, wow, how can I participate in compassion?
但在他的案例中，他不是在倾听辨别力。相反，他是在倾听同情心。我的整个旅程是找到一扇能让我敞开心扉去理解同情心如何在监狱系统中运作的大门。我看到狱警承受着很多痛苦和折磨，我说，哇，这个狱警可能正要回家见他的儿子。我会看到暴力，我说，哇，我怎么能参与到同情心中呢？
And I start realizing that we all suffer to some degree or another, and that I was not alone. Jarvis also uses that compassion to connect with his fellow inmates. Just getting enough space to find quiet, to find stoneness in oneself allowed him to notice the little scars on the men men on their hands or on their faces. And he would occasionally ask about those, hey, what happened? You know, knowing that there was a story, it was a story that probably led to a really tough childhood, a broken foster care
我开始意识到我们都在某种程度上遭受痛苦，我并不孤单。贾维斯也利用那种同情心与他的狱友建立联系。仅仅获得足够的空间去寻找安静，在自己内心找到静止，就让他能够注意到男人们手上或脸上的小伤疤。他偶尔会问起那些，嘿，发生了什么？你知道，知道背后有一个故事，那是一个可能导致非常艰难的童年、破碎的寄养
system, violence at home. So for him, silence has a direct connection to compassion, and that changes his relationship to the men he's with. In return, the other inmates help Jarvis cultivate that silence. For instance, if someone is calling out his name, the other guys will say, hey Jarvis is on the phone or Jarvis is writing to help guard his silence. So he can, perhaps, just be left alone or be undisturbed on a conversation or be able to dive into some writing. And I just loved learning that they do that.
系统、家庭暴力的故事。所以对他来说，沉默与同情心有着直接的联系，这改变了他与他所处男人们的关系。作为回报，其他囚犯帮助贾维斯培养那种沉默。例如，如果有人在喊他的名字，其他人会说，嘿，贾维斯在打电话，或者贾维斯在写信，以帮助守护他的沉默。这样他就可以，也许，只是被单独留下，或者在谈话中不被打扰，或者能够沉浸在写作中。我真的很喜欢知道他们会这样做。
When Lee and Justin first started working on their book, they were thinking of silence as an absence of sound. But after speaking with people like Cyrus and Jarvis, they realized that silence is about much more than that. There's an engagement, there's an aliveness, when we're really engaging silence, we're engaging this presence that's teaming with life, and joy, and ecstasy. Even in noisy, busy circumstances, we can tune into these little moments of silence, and they have the capacity to bring us healing in our minds and our bodies, and it has the power to reshape our perspectives, our views of the world, and feel some more optimism.
当李和贾斯汀刚开始写他们的书时，他们认为沉默是声音的缺失。但在与赛勒斯和贾维斯这样的人交谈后，他们意识到沉默不仅仅是那样。有一种参与，有一种活力，当我们真正参与沉默时，我们是在参与这种充满生命、快乐和狂喜的存在。即使在嘈杂、忙碌的环境中，我们也可以调入这些小小的沉默时刻，它们有能力为我们的思想和身体带来治愈，并有力量重塑我们的视角、我们对世界的看法，并感受到更多的乐观。
But engaging with silence is just the first step. We're living in this culture where success is defined by whether or not we win the argument, whether we have the last word. But I kept coming back to this intuition that the answers might not come just through more thinking or talking. The answers might not come through making more and more noise. The answers might come through silence. And the more you practice finding silence, the more you'll get out of it. I thought it would be more like the first few months
但参与沉默只是第一步。我们生活在这样一种文化中，成功被定义为我们是否赢得了争论，我们是否有最后一句话。但我一直回到这种直觉，答案可能不仅仅是通过更多的思考或谈话得来的。答案可能不是通过制造越来越多的噪音得来的。答案可能通过沉默得来。你练习寻找沉默越多，你从中得到的就越多。我以为它会更像
of a relationship when you think like, oh, this is exciting, this is cool, this is different. But I think people who are in happy marriages will know. A marriage is not just that exciting first date played out over and over and over again. It's something much more profound than that. This is the kind of joy, the kind of contentedness that lets me fall asleep immediately. No matter who you are or where you are, silence is always available. Silence isn't fancy, it doesn't require equipment, it doesn't require
一段关系的头几个月，当你觉得，哦，这很令人兴奋，这很酷，这很不同。但我认为处于幸福婚姻中的人会知道。婚姻不仅仅是那种令人兴奋的第一次约会一遍又一遍地重演。它比那深刻得多。这是一种快乐，一种让我能立即入睡的满足感。无论你是谁，无论你在哪里，沉默总是可用的。沉默并不花哨，它不需要设备，它不需要
gadgetry. It belongs to everyone, we all have access to it, it's innate to being human. At some point of the day I realized my silence is my best friend. And it brings me to that point where I'm in a state of gratitude. And that says a lot to me because I've seen the worst, you know? It just blows me away that, but be required, you can receive these kinds of gifts. You can get this kind of knowledge. It's given me the gift of having realized what time means to me. The two stories you just heard came from the book Golden, the power of silence in a world of noise. In the book, you'll find 12 other stories circling around the concept of silence.
小玩意。它属于每个人，我们都有权获得它，它是人类与生俱来的。在一天中的某个时刻，我意识到我的沉默是我最好的朋友。它把我带到了那种我处于感恩状态的点。这对我来说意义重大，因为我见过最糟糕的情况，你知道？这让我感到震惊，但被要求，你可以收到这些礼物。你可以获得这种知识。它给了我意识到时间对我意味着什么的礼物。你刚才听到的两个故事来自《金色的沉默：喧嚣世界中的静谧力量》。在书中，你会发现另外12个围绕沉默概念的故事。
Take a moment to go buy it wherever you get your books. It's also available as an audio book. 20,000 Hurtz is produced out of the sound design studios of De facto Sound. This episode was written and produced by Andrew Anderson and Casey Emerling. With help from Grace East. It was sound designed and mixed by Brandon Pratt. And Nick Spradlin, with original music by Wesley Slover. Thanks to our guests, Jarvis J. Masters, Cyrus Habib, Lee Mars, and Justin Zorn,
花点时间去你买书的地方买一本。它也有有声书版本。《20,000 Hertz》由De facto Sound的声音设计工作室制作。本期节目由安德鲁·安德森（Andrew Anderson）和凯西·埃默林（Casey Emerling）撰写和制作。格蕾丝·伊斯特（Grace East）提供了帮助。由布兰登·普拉特（Brandon Pratt）和尼克·斯普拉德林（Nick Spradlin）进行声音设计和混音，原创音乐由韦斯利·斯洛弗（Wesley Slover）创作。感谢我们的嘉宾贾维斯·J·马斯特斯、赛勒斯·哈比卜、李·马尔斯和贾斯汀·佐恩，
to find out more about Jarvis' case and his latest appeal, follow the link in the show description. A special thanks to Courtney Cole for sharing her interviews with Jarvis. Courtney's podcast, Dear Governor, is a deep dive into Jarvis' life story and his ongoing legal battle.
要了解更多关于贾维斯的案件和他最新的上诉，请点击节目描述中的链接。特别感谢考特尼·科尔（Courtney Cole）分享她对贾维斯的采访。考特尼的播客《亲爱的州长》（Dear Governor）深入探讨了贾维斯的人生故事和他正在进行的法律斗争。
Both seasons are available now. I'm Dallas Taylor. Thanks for listening. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
两季现在都已上线。我是达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）。感谢收听。你。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。